Good afternoon everyone, and welcome to our first cross-regional sync of the month. We have an hour together. Three things on the agenda: where each region stands against the quarter, our marquee deals — Daimaru, Corso del Centro, and MetroPharma — and any cross-regional blockers I should know about. A reminder that AI Interpreter is enabled for English and Mandarin, so Mei Lin can speak in Mandarin and the rest of us will see the live translation. The Facilitator agent is also generating both live notes and a doc summary for me to circulate. Mei Lin, let's start with APAC.
谢谢 Mat。APAC 这个季度的表现正在快速回升。我们目前的业绩是计划的 96%,主要的拉升来自两个故事:一个是东京的 Daimaru 续约,我们上周五已经把客户的三大异议都解决了,合同书初稿这周送出,预计下周可以拿到客户的口头承诺;另一个是孟买的 SMB 集群,Priya 和 Wei 这一周已经推进了五个交易到接近签约的阶段。我有一个请求:Daimaru 的 CIO 希望我们这边的执行层进一步介入,Mat 你是否方便在三月底之前直接和他通一次电话?
Thanks Mei Lin — I followed that very clearly via the interpreter. Yes, I am happy to take that call. Please send me three time slots and the briefing pack by end of next week and I will lock it in. Great work on the Daimaru save plan and the Mumbai momentum. Lucas, please go.
Thanks Mat. EMEA is tracking 103 percent year-to-date, with Southern Europe leading. The marquee story this cycle is Corso del Centro in Milan. Their CIO has personally engaged with our local team, asked us to host a partner conversation this Friday, and specifically asked who our executive sponsor would be. That is the ask I want to surface to you: I'd like to nominate you as the exec sponsor on Corso, and if Corso eventually expands into a Pan-European retail tech consortium, we would loop in the CVP. Otherwise, Nordic Apparel is on track to close within two weeks and we have a fresh inbound from Istanbul that Yusuf is qualifying.
I will take exec sponsorship on Corso. Please send me the same briefing pack format you use for Mat-on-Daimaru and let's align on the Italian-language considerations — Chiara will know best. Sophia, your turn.
Thanks Mat. AMER is at 102 percent on commit. The marquee deal is MetroPharma in New York. The compliance package went to the customer this Monday after a full team effort, and we are awaiting their feedback. Marcus and Ryan have prepared response material for any product-config follow-ups, so I expect a decision within the next two weeks. Beyond MetroPharma, our LATAM pipeline is starting to take shape and Isabella is preparing a Sao Paulo partner sync targeting week five. Nothing I need from you today other than support if MetroPharma needs an executive nudge later this month.
Noted. Please flag the MetroPharma decision the moment you hear so I can react. On LATAM, please keep me informed on the Sao Paulo partner sync — that could be a Q2 conversation with the CVP. Now, let me ask one cross-regional question. We have three marquee storylines: Daimaru, Corso, and MetroPharma. Are there any cross-regional learnings worth surfacing? For example, is there a common compliance or integration objection pattern we should systematize?
Mat,这是一个很好的问题。我观察到的是,我们三个区域的大客户在合同流程的最后阶段都遇到了关于数据驻留和集成成本的问题。这不是孤立的现象。也许我们应该让产品团队提前一步,把这两类回应模板化,这样我们就不需要每次重新发明轮子。
I strongly agree with Mei Lin. On Corso and on Istanbul we are hearing the same data residency question. If product can publish a roadmap-backed response template for the top five jurisdictions, our cycle time on these objections drops by weeks.
Plus one from AMER. MetroPharma's compliance package was four items, three of them have already appeared in EMEA conversations Lucas's team mentioned. Let's standardize.
Great signal. I'll take an action item to engage the product compliance team this week and ask them to publish a top-five-jurisdictions response template by end of this cycle. Anika will follow up with a kickoff note tomorrow.
Perfect. Let me recap so the Facilitator captures everything cleanly for the doc summary. Action one: I take exec sponsorship on Daimaru and Corso, with a direct customer call for Daimaru before end of March. Action two: Sophia flags MetroPharma decision the moment it arrives. Action three: I engage product compliance for a cross-region response template on top-five jurisdictions. Action four: Anika circulates a recap brief before our next cross-regional sync. Mei Lin, anything more in Mandarin you want captured before we close?
没有别的,Mat,谢谢你抽出时间。这次 AI 翻译效果非常好,我能够用最舒服的语言表达细节。下次见。
Wonderful — and the interpreter performed beautifully on my side as well. Lucas, Sophia, anything to add?
Nothing more. Thank you Mat.
All set. Talk in two weeks.
Great. Facilitator is generating the meeting doc and the AI Interpreter scripts in English and Mandarin are saved with the meeting artifacts. Anika will circulate within 24 hours. Thanks all — closing the meeting.